Joston Ramon Theney, Screenwriter, Author,
Director, Producer: We went just thinking about it
if you go back and you think what do
I remember from the film I remember?
Film Courage: How often have
you read a screenplay where
nothing happens in the first 10 minutes no
scares nothing all too often all too often um
i think that because the software now
can format things for you and everybody
learns about final draft or or movie magic or
whatever they learn about these these different
programs it's easy to make your screenplay
look professional it's only when you
start to read it do you do you understand the
level of craft that they're at right now right and
in certain levels of craft there's always that oh
we're building to something great we're building
to something great and that's at a certain
level right and they may be really really good
at crafting a story and dialogue and things may
seem okay but if nothing is happening and nothing
is happening by page 10 nothing is happening by
page 15 but page 20 when is something gonna happen
I do I do read a lot of scripts where I
wonder that or I wonder what is the point
what is the point what are you trying to say even
if you have nothing to say what is the point of
the film who's your hero what is this person going
through how does going through this change them
how does going through this and them changing
help them deal with the true protect antagonist
all those things all those questions they aren't
answered because they aren't at that level yet
you know so you're gonna get a mismatch
but for the most part I would say out of
if I read
10 screenplays
something happens by page 10
in one of them depending upon which week
it is not every time does something happen
not all the time does it sometimes
it might be one out of 20 screenplays
what if someone says well I want to take my time
with the suspense I mean if you look back at The
Stepford Wives and I realize that's not really
horror it's more thriller it was a long intro to
them coming to this new neighborhood and seeing
these wives and and she's kind of confused about
what's going on I mean it took its time yeah
but the thing about it is it establishes its
tone very quickly and I feel that's another
thing that's missing because so many people
haven't found their voice how they tell a story
right because your story may change depending upon
whatever genre you've decided to write today
whatever got into you love story that I wanted
that I'm writing right now moon in the stars it's
it's a it's people hear me say it's a love story
and you think oh romantic drama and I'm actually
no it's a sci-fi is sci-fi these people are
interstellar travelers interdimensional travelers
time travelers and they can do this and they can
do that and but then where's the love portion
well the love portions here and it's but it's a
completely different thing than ever written once
in one is a very completely different story than
ever written I think that people classify that one
as a suspense drama or drama thriller or something
that so and that's very different than the horror
that directed and even within the horror directed
many different types of horror so no matter what
the genre is that you're writing in you have to
at some point have developed your voice and how
how how a person recognizes that it's your film
right and then once you start to develop your
voice I think it'll help you drastically with
maintaining tone of a film because your voice
is your voice and it's how you tell the story
and as long as you understand the tone of
your own film you can keep that modulated
all the way through and you can set that at the
very beginning then once you set that tone this
is where this story takes place in this
type of world you start that from page one
you start it from page one so yes nothing may
happen in terms of someone getting murdered
or whatever you may not get the horror in the
because it may not be a horror maybe it's just
a movie that's meant to make you squirm and make
you uncomfortable maybe that's what it is or maybe
the story is speaking to with once and one it was
about a guy who didn't even know himself anymore
so if he doesn't know himself he doesn't even
recognize himself in certain situations and if you
tell him he's done something wrong he's relying on
your truth to tell him he's done something wrong
because he doesn't even know right and wrong of
himself anymore and I showed that from page one
if you can't even recognize who you are and
what you do in the situation when someone
tells you to make it better how can you he's
how do I how do I do it and the person has to
tell him I think that's something you can figure
out and he's I don't think he can he really can't
it sets the tone for the film nobody died
nobody was hunted down in the first 10 pages
I just set the tone for for what the story is
and I think that that's once you it takes a while
before you get to that level of understanding
of of what you're doing and then I think
now you've gotten to a point where technically
you're proficient but you still have so much more
so many more levels to climb do you think
it's better that someone rushes into
a more of a horrific scene or takes their time
which which is more detrimental to a horror script
too long to get into the action or too fast I mean
again I i think it depends on the the point of
the story I think that scream which is one of my
faves from the 90s it in the first film it kind of
meanders right at first in the first minute or two
she picks up the phone she's talking to the guy
and making popcorn everything seems fine it seems
very casual it's not until the first kind of slip
up that she doesn't hear that we heard is
the audience that we realize wait a minute
and then you start to you start to sit forward
right the story is about a guy who calls you on
the phone he stabs you to death we didn't see that
until it came in probably around the five-minute
mark is when we started to be concerned right
so in that first five minutes it's are we just
following this lady and if you notice that movie
is really for the longest time it's a single shot
it's a single shot she picks up the
phone and they pull away from the phone
they're following her around into the
kitchen it's a single shot for a lot of it
and even when they abandon it they pick it
up on another another wonder and they're
walking around and it's masterfully done
but it's all about the pacing and the tone
and it slowly becomes more menacing and
once it becomes menacing it never lets up
and so again less about dialogue and more about
camera movement camera movement and just really
understanding tone I think lighting plays an
incredible cinematography in general plays
an incredible role in creating tone your
cinematography your editing post-production
sound musical cues sound effect all that stuff
plays a huge role in it but when you're reading
it on the page when you're on the page it has
something has to set the tone for me to understand
why I should care and a lot of the times I ask
why should I care very early I'll ask that on page
sometimes too I'll ask why should I care now
something may not happen until page three or
page four but I'll be asking myself why do I care
when I watch movies at home I'll turn them on
i'll watch for a little bit but then I'll turn it
because there's so much content that's available
right now why would I waste time I treat
a movie that I'm watching just I would a
script that I'm reading I start watching and if
it's not catching my attention I have to abandon
I have to abandon it I think it was harder before
because there was so little you couldn't check a
phone you couldn't have one window open and be
over here you had to you were just all right
I'll let it play and sometimes that worked with
advantage because then it grew on you but now
you have to catch people that's what I was
asking if you knew the analytics of when
people dropped out or if people
rewound a scene or something
yeah I don't have it in terms of analytics
from from amazon I don't have it when someone
maybe rewinds it or something I don't
have that but I do know I can tell
the progression people are dropping out dropping
out dropping out dropping out oh it stabilized
and then people watched it all the way through
here and then it dropped out I can tell that but
I can't really tell did they pause it and then go
do something and come back I can't tell those sort
of things or that they rewind you can't really
see that but the thing about it is is that I
usually will start my films and I try to get them
to a point where you don't feel there's a place
to jump off because something's always building
to something else and one scene leads into the
next very naturally so I'm constantly trying
to do that so it doesn't feel there's a place
to really drop off or you'll feel you're missing
something because something just happened so now
I have to see how that affects the next thing I'm
constantly trying to to keep that momentum going
and I think that's what you you have to do or
what you should aspire to do when you're doing
anything something it always has to be building
towards something or what else are we doing
why would I be investing my time if if nothing in
your script is investing towards something bigger
so a bigger character goal or a bigger
scare or or something with the antagonist
yeah set up your stakes give me a character
who's who's interesting that I care about
even if you don't want to root for them to succeed
root for them to not succeed something give the
audience something to to to to keep them invested
and keep them interested and it does start with
having something in the first few pages whether
it's tone whether it's an act of whatever that
drives the story forward give them something that
keeps them watching more importantly something
that lets them know what kind of a ride they're
on sure because even with hereditary we didn't
totally know we just knew something ominous yes
was there and it kind of keeps you on the edge
and you didn't know what was it though yeah and
the great thing about hereditary right now is if
if you if we talk about hereditary the first
thing we do is go hereditary we went just thinking
about it right but if you if you go back and you
think what do I remember from the film I remember
there was this little sibling thing with
the brother and the sister I remember her
head hit that pole and it came off and then I
remember he didn't want to he just parked the
car and went into the house I remember the thing
from him in the classroom where his face kind of
went crazy and he slammed his head on the desk and
stuff I remember that and then I remember all the
stuff that happened at the end with him with the
mother and the father bursting into flames and all
that stuff and the mom banging her head but we're
recalling just these few moments but the fact is
is that we made it to the end in complete
terror because of the tone of the film
the tone was set very early and they never let up
even when they had moments where it looked hope
was starting to shine in through the window it
didn't matter the tone was so dark and ominous and
heavy that you just you felt oh and you felt cold
I don't know if anybody I felt cold watching it
it was it was such a weird feeling that you got
watching that movie but they kept that tone up
throughout the entire film and that's what
I mean is it's finding your tone and staying
with it very early something that makes
people care and make them keep watching.